[Music]
family of Aretha Franklin continues to
plan memorial events following the
legendary soul singers death on Thursday
at the age of 76 her funeral will be
held at a four thousand seat Church in
her native Detroit just a few miles down
the road from the church that sewed the
Queens of Souls royal roots back in 2011
for CBS Sunday morning
I had a chance to go to that church with
Aretha
this is your spot this is where I sit
when I come to church this is where this
is my seat don't sit in my seat father
the charismatic Reverend CL Franklin who
was pastor he would Electrify audiences
with his thunderous sir
[Music]
then he called his daughter up to the
pulpit my dad had to push me the same
though I really didn't want to sing
Aretha was about ten years old I'm
standing up on a little box a box
yeah the pulpit was too high so they put
a little box next to the pulpit so this
was this was your place yeah this is
where we lived we went back to the
Franklin family home in West Detroit you
were saying in the day it was a
showplace yeah it was definitely a
showplace it was the most beautiful home
I had ever seen there was a room right
the second floor yeah right there when
gospel greats like Mahalia Jackson or
Clara ward would visit the house the
young Aretha would watch from the top of
the stairs see who was coming in and who
was going out and peopling through the
railing of the staircase so it was
special yeah very very special who did
you like to see most of all anytime
Aretha 's life was also marked by
tragedy her mother who moved away when
she was six died four years later in her
autobiography
Aretha wrote I cannot describe the pain
nor will I try in 1979 her father was
shot during a burglary in their Detroit
home he lingered in a coma for five
years before his death when we were
trying to get the car
Aretha asked the city to dedicate a
local park to him she wanted us to see
it
but as we approached the park she was
overcome by emotion that still means a
lot - it took a minute for her to
compose herself
it's beautiful park I'm glad they
dedicated it to you
Reverend Franklin envisioned a great
career for his talented daughter but
likely even he did not imagine she would
live to perform at the inauguration of
the first african-american president
[Music]
that goes down in history I'm thankful
that I was a part of that pretty amazing
life incur that she had and what an
extraordinary day that was I will I will
never forget that day was there one
standout mobile they were cut me and
obviously she got very emotional talking
about her father very unexpectedly when
we approached the park I remember that
and I will always remember her blushing
when she mentioned it was like she was
that 14 year old girl again at the top
of the stairs you know the only
beautiful thing in the last couple of
days has been all the songs that we've
gotten to hear over and over and over
and that's the thing and that's what
will survive it's one of the most
incredible catalogs I mean I think of
her as the greatest singer of our time
just an incredible voice an incredible
emotion such an original too and you
know that tableau of that ending shot
they're really just so symbolic so
powerful things Anthony